Buonasera a tutti. Allora, questa sera concludiamo questa trilogia sulla prima guerra mondiale
dell'Italia raccontando l'ultimo anno della guerra, da Caporetto a Vittorio Veneto. Devo
essere sincero, fin da subito, è una storia meno surreale rispetto a quella dell'entrata
in guerra dell'Italia e meno tragica rispetto alla storia di Caporetto. Ormai siete qui
tanto, comunque è un pezzo di storia d'Italia che credo valga comunque la pena di esaminare
un po' più da vicino. Dopo Caporetto dunque, l'attacco austriaco e soprattutto tedesco
è scattato il 24 ottobre del 1917, nel giro di due settimane quel che resta dell'esercito
italiano è stato sbalzato indietro fino al piave. Tanto per capirci, in una guerra in cui
si misuravano a chilometri, un chilometro per volta, le avanzate vittoriose. In una guerra
dove l'undicesima battaglia del Lisonzo, che noi abbiamo vinto, la battaglia della Bainsizza,
ha portato l'esercito italiano a andare avanti di 8-10 chilometri e quegli 8-10 chilometri
di avanzata hanno dato ai comandi austriaci la sensazione che la prossima volta crollava
tutto. I tedeschi a Caporetto ci hanno ributtato indietro di 150 chilometri. Siamo in Italia, un pezzo
d'Italia è occupata, le colonne di prigionieri italiani che marciano verso oriente incrociano
le colonne dei tedeschi che vanno avanti, la pancia piena perché si sono fermati a mangiare
dappertutto, entusiasti felici per la vittoria. Quando piove con gli ombrelli aperti, perché le
colonne tedesche saccheggiano gli ombrelli nelle case e per un po' marciano riparandosi con l'ombrello
fino a quando i loro comandi non decidono che non è una cosa adatta a dei veri uomini e quindi lo
proibiscono. I tedeschi incrociano le colonne dei nostri prigionieri e scherzando gli dicono
a Milano, a Milano, stiamo andando a Milano. Ogni tanto qualche ufficiale italiano prigioniero si
trova a fare due chiacchiere con un ufficiale austriaco che parla italiano, un ufficiale austriaco
che magari è di Trieste e che gli dice, anche questo ho trovato in una memoria, adesso noi andiamo a Roma
a ciappare il gobetto, dove il gobetto sarebbe il revittorio naturalmente. E invece non vanno a Milano
e non vanno a Roma, si fermano al Piave. La prima domanda che sempre si pone in questi casi è appunto
ma perché si sono fermati al Piave? Com'è che l'esercito italiano è riuscito a fermarsi lì? Qui le risposte
in realtà sono tante, come sempre quando uno dice perché è successa una cosa? E non c'è mai un solo
motivo, ce ne sono tanti. La tentazione dello storico sarebbe di dire ma avete mai avuto esempi
nella storia di una vittoria dopo la quale chi ha vinto conquista tutto il mondo? No, ci si ferma sempre,
sempre quando hai vinto prima o poi ti fermi. Fermarsi al Piave dopo 150 chilometri di corsa è il minimo,
i tedeschi sono esausti, hanno lasciato indietro tutta la loro artiglieria prima di portarla avanti
ce ne vuole, gli aeroporti, i magazzini, le linee ferroviarie, è tutto indietro e le truppe sono
stravolte, esauste, non ce la fanno più. Arrivati al Piave e al Grappa in quel novembre del 17, ci
provano ancora, ci sperano anche e invece lì non passano. Quel che resta dell'esercito italiano
tiene duro ed è la prima sensazione all'improvviso in Italia che forse dopo tutto ecco non tutto è
perduto. L'esercito nonostante le botte che ha preso c'è ancora e combatte ancora, anzi a dirla tutta
combatte meglio di prima perché quel che resta dell'esercito adesso sta combattendo in Italia ed è
più facile spiegare ai soldati perché si combatte. Certo anche prima i soldati dicevano la patria,
il risorgimento, l'unità d'Italia, Trento, Trieste, sta di fatto che le truppe italiane che sono state
attaccate e travolte a Caporetto vivevano da due anni in un paese straniero, abitato da stranieri,
sloveni, i quali li detestavano e li consideravano giustamente degli invasori e i nostri soldati
tanto contenti non erano. Adesso invece si combatte in Italia e la propaganda nostra lo capisce subito
è su questo che bisogna battere, ai soldati bisogna spiegarlo e non è difficile. Guardate che di là non
se ne sono mica andati tutti, certo mezzo milione di profughi se ne sono andati dai territori oltre il
piave ma tantissimi sono rimasti e la nostra propaganda ai soldati insiste a dire questo
pensate a quelli che sono rimasti dall'altra parte, pensate alle donne, le sentite gridare le donne
e loro un po' le sentono davvero e un po' se lo immaginano ma insomma che sul piave vale la pena
di resistere è più facile farlo capire e i soldati combattono meglio di prima.
Poi ci sono anche altri motivi, non bisogna assolutamente sottovalutare il fatto che i nostri
alleati sono venuti giù a darci una mano, non che ci vogliano bene però il pericolo che l'Italia
esca dalla guerra, che il nemico davvero arrivi a Milano ecco è troppo forte, perciò gli inglesi e i
francesi ci hanno mandato truppe, tante truppe, entro fine novembre per capirci sono schierate sul
fronte italiano 11 divisioni inglesi e francesi, 11 divisioni e più dell'intera terza armata, noi nel
corso della ritirata abbiamo celebrato la terza armata comandata dal duca d'Aosta che mentre la
seconda armata si è fatta sbaragliare a caporetto ecco la terza armata è tornata indietro intatta,
invitta, poi per decenni la retorica celebrerà in Italia l'invitta terza armata, le 11 divisioni
mandate dai nostri alleati da sole sono di più dell'intera terza armata e non è solo questo,
bisogna anche dirlo gli inglesi e i francesi hanno eserciti di qualità superiore, gli inglesi
e i francesi combattono da tre anni in Francia contro il migliore esercito del mondo, i tedeschi,
noi quando ci siamo trovati di fronte ai tedeschi ci siamo sbriciolati a caporetto, gli inglesi e i
francesi sono tre anni che tengono botta anche se con grande fatica bisogna dire, sono altri eserciti,
hanno un'altra professionalità e altri mezzi, altre economie alle spalle, già prima di caporetto
noi avevamo delle batterie inglesi di artiglieria mandate per amicizia simbolicamente sul nostro
fronte e gli ufficiali inglesi di artiglieria, ci sono i loro diari, i loro libri, dicono l'esercito
italiano i soldati sono coraggiosissimi, è pazzesco come vanno a farsi ammazzare i soldati, gli uomini
ufficiali, ma quanto a tecnica, quanto a competenza poco, l'artiglieria ha tanti cannoni però fa poco e
poi hanno poche risorse, fuoco normale per una batteria italiana significa sparare sei colpi
all'ora, per una batteria inglese significa sparare trenta colpi all'ora e la differenza si vede, c'è una
diversa competenza tattica, diversi armamenti, se ne accorgono gli austriaci, gli austriaci sono
abituati a combattere con noi e con noi se la giocano alla pari, ma nel dicembre sul monte tomba
gli austriaci si trovano di fronte ai francesi e i francesi li fanno a pezzi, dunque l'aiuto degli inglesi
e dei francesi è una cosa consistente, significativa e dà una mano al nostro esercito che si sta in
realtà rimettendo in piedi, gli sbandati ammassati in enormi campi di concentramento pian piano vengono
rimessi in riga, riprendono il fucile, vengono distribuiti ai reparti e i reparti vanno in linea e
combattono, dopodiché naturalmente nella nostra storiografia si è sempre molto insistito sul fatto
che dopo il disastro di Caporetto abbiamo imparato qualcosa, è cambiato il comando, è cambiato lo stile
di comando, Cadorna è andato via, adesso c'è Diaz e se voi andate a vedere nella divulgazione, nella
manualistica, si insiste molto sul diverso modo più umano di comandare che Diaz avrebbe portato con sé,
maggior comprensione per i soldati, per la loro mentalità, più licenze, più distrazioni, meno
fucilazioni, allora è vero in parte, Diaz personalmente c'entra poco probabilmente, chi è Diaz? Di solito si dice
sempre hanno nominato uno sconosciuto con grande sorpresa di tutti, è abbastanza vero, intendiamoci,
Armando Diaz non è uno sconosciuto per i suoi colleghi, è un comandante di corpo d'armata e pur
sempre sua eccellenza il tenente generale Armando Diaz, ce ne saranno 30 o 40 come lui nell'esercito,
sono troppi perché il pubblico li possa conoscere, lo mettono quando lo spiegano agli alleati, il re
Vittorio per esempio agli alleati, agli inglesi e ai francesi spiega abbiamo questo Diaz, è bravissimo,
e il migliore abbiamo messo lui, la verità vera probabilmente è che hanno messo lui perché non
volevano rischiare qualcuno più importante, perché non erano tanto sicuri di come andava a finire,
ci sarebbe stato il duca d'Aosta, il comandante della terza armata, cugino del re, ma dai il comando
supremo al duca d'Aosta in un momento in cui non sappiamo se non va a finire tutto molto male,
si è già bruciato Cadorna, ne bruciamo un altro, il re Vittorio che su questo tema tornava spesso
senza immaginare che tanti anni dopo gli sarebbe toccato davvero, il re Vittorio dice beh se va male
e mi tocca abdicare è meglio che ci sia mio cugino pronto, quindi non lo mettiamo al comando
dell'esercito, mettiamo uno che anche se va tutto male e ci siamo bruciati Diaz, pazienza,
poi invece Diaz riesce, Diaz e i suoi collaboratori, fra i quali spiace dirlo, Badoglio il quale ha
delle grosse responsabilità per Caporetto ma dopo, dopo come vice capo di stato maggiore è uno che
dà un'impronta forte di modernizzazione all'esercito italiano, è anche per quello che poi la commissione
l'inchiesta su Caporetto non lo tocca Badoglio perché è diventato un uomo prezioso, Diaz e Badoglio
cambiano tante cose, cosa cambia per esempio? Il modo di fare propaganda con i soldati, che con i soldati
si debba fare propaganda perché quello che pensano i soldati è importante, Cadorna avrebbe detto ma perché
i soldati pensano, ma figuriamoci, milione di analfabeti, invece i soldati pensano e sentono,
i nuovi comandanti lo capiscono meglio questo, bisogna fare propaganda quindi, non che non si facesse
anche prima la propaganda, prima di Caporetto qualcuno aveva cominciato a capirlo, questa idea,
bisogna organizzare dei discorsi, delle conferenze per i soldati, questa idea circolava già un po' prima
di Caporetto ma se uno va a vedere come veniva realizzata in pratica, ecco ve lo racconto come
veniva realizzata in pratica, una delle divisioni che vengono travolte a Caporetto, la cinquantesima
divisione, pochi giorni prima dell'offensiva nemica il generale comandante della cinquantesima
divisione in Conca di Plezzo all'improvviso si sveglia, è un vecchio signore, all'improvviso si sveglia
già già già la propaganda, la conferenza, è stata fatta la conferenza, si generale gli dicono stia
tranquillo è stata fatta la conferenza, la conferenza è consistita in questo, una sala come
questa piena di alpini, il conferenziere è un capitano dei bersaglieri, ultra settantenne,
veterano della terza guerra di indipendenza, ferito a custozza, grande patriota che allo scoppio
della guerra si è di nuovo arruolato, è capitano dei bersaglieri, a settant'anni non sanno cosa fargli
fare, adesso c'è questa cosa nuova delle conferenze, gli fanno fare le conferenze, per cui a una sala
piena di alpini il veterano di custozza appoggiato alla sua gruccia di mutilato tiene una conferenza
sul tema è bello morire per la patria, ho trovato anche il rapporto del comandante di quegli alpini
che dice la sala rumoreggiava, adesso invece la propaganda si comincia a prenderla sul serio, nasce
nell'esercito italiano il servizio P, propaganda, e la propaganda la fanno gli intellettuali migliori
che ci sono sul campo, vengono arruolati in tanti, Prezzolini, Salvemini, Piero Calamandrei,
Ardengo Soffici, scrittori, poeti, intellettuali di tutti i tipi, gente in gamba che la prende sul serio
questa cosa e che capisce che ai soldati appunto devi cercare di parlare in un certo modo, devi dirgli
delle cose semplici, dall'altra parte ci sono le donne, andiamo a liberarle prima o poi, nascono i
giornalini per i soldati, alcuni sono famosi, oggi i collezionisti ne hanno appunto gli scaffali pieni,
la tradotta, giornalini fatti bene, non roba buttata via, alla tradotta collaborano i giornalisti del
Corriere della Sera, il che vuole anche dire i disegnatori della Domenica del Corriere, del Corriere
dei Piccoli, ci sarebbe da scrivere un libro su come il Corriere dei Piccoli ha formato generazioni
di borghesi italiani e poi si spinge sul fatto che appunto i soldati bisogna trattarli meglio,
devono mangiare meglio, prima di Caporetto mangiavano da cani e nella ritirata hanno scoperto
che era pieno di depositi strapieni di ogni ben di Dio e hanno dovuto dare fuoco a tutto per non
lasciarlo a nemico, non deve più succedere, la roba buona deve arrivare in trincea nelle gamelle
dei soldati e poi mandarli in licenza, prima li mandavano il meno possibile perché Cadorna era
convinto che il soldato che va in licenza arriva nel paese, nel paese gli dicono oh questa guerra
quando è che la finite, basta facciamo la rivoluzione e il soldato torna al fronte e non ha più voglia di
combattere, questo era il chiodo fisso di Cadorna, quindi in licenza non li mandiamo, adesso invece li
mandano molto di più in licenza e il riposo deve essere vero riposo, non ginnastica, fatica,
esercitazioni, il riposo, ci sono degli iscritti, dei generali di quest'epoca che dicono no no,
quando si mandano gli uomini a riposo deve essere riposo davvero, ci deve essere un paese, un fiume,
un'osteria, delle donne che veramente la gente sappia che dopo aver combattuto un po' vengono anche i
momenti belli e tutte queste cose insieme un po' cominciano a incidere, il morale dei combattenti
comincia un po' a risalire e anche nel paese in generale è uno di quei rari momenti in cui, come dire,
nel paese domina una certa sobrietà, la tendenza è a dire c'eravamo montati la testa, Caporetto ci ha
insegnato qualcosa, per esempio gli stessi militari cominciano a criticare i giornalisti,
i famosi giornalisti come Luigi Barzini del Corriere della Sera che erano odiati dai soldati
perché quando un soldato per caso sentiva leggere un articolo del Corriere della Sera che descriveva
una battaglia e non ci ritrovava la sua vita vera, i giornali parlavano di avanzate eroiche,
gloriose, ufficiali paterni, bandiere al vento e il soldato che sapeva benissimo che le cose erano
diverse, odiava i giornalisti e si deprimeva, gli stessi ufficiali cominciano a dire basta,
basta bugie, basta retorica, cominciamo a raccontare le cose come stanno, sarà un breve momento,
durano sempre poco i momenti in cui si dice niente retorica, ecco, ma in quel momento c'è
l'eterna Italia pomposa e parolaia per un momento attraversa un bagno di sobrietà e di realismo
e così nel novembre-dicembre l'offensiva tedesca e austriaca si esaurisce sul piave e sul grappa e a
quel punto i tedeschi dicono agli austriaci siete contenti? Siamo venuti, abbiamo fatto quello che
volevate, molto di più, li abbiamo ributtati indietro fino al piave, adesso sono fatti i vostri,
a noi le truppe tedesche ci servono in Francia, entro gennaio non c'è più un soldato tedesco in
Italia, rimangono i soliti vecchi austriaci con i quali già da prima ce la giocavamo alla pari
tutto sommato e c'è il piave fra noi e loro, passa l'inverno, passa la primavera, gli austriaci
non hanno abbastanza forze per attaccare e noi assolutamente non abbiamo le forze per attaccare
noi, quindi si rimane lì a guardarsi da una parte all'altra del piave. Si va avanti, la primavera
declina nell'estate e si comincia a avere nel mondo la sensazione che forse quest'anno questa
guerra potrebbe arrivare alla conclusione. I tedeschi in Francia, ne riparleremo, scatenano
una serie di offensive come dire o la va o la spacca, ci bruciamo tutto, se va bene arriviamo
a Parigi. Gli austriaci decidono che anche loro devono fare qualcosa, dopo tutto a Caporetto è andata
così bene. Certo ma a Caporetto c'erano i tedeschi, adesso i tedeschi non ci sono più, ma gli austriaci
raccolgono lo stesso tutte le forze che gli restano per attaccare di nuovo, attaccheranno per cercare di
passare il piave, sfondare e far crollare il fronte italiano. L'offensiva è programmata per giugno, è programmata
con attenzione come al solito in tutti i particolari, anche la propaganda, le poste imperiali stampano
francobolli in cui si vede un Erculeo guerriero che abbatte a colpi di clava un gatto, il quale gatto
siamo noi, gli italiani. Qui faccio una piccola digressione, tanto siamo all'ultima sera ce lo possiamo
permettere, perché gli italiani sono accostati ai gatti. Ebbene esiste un soprannome insultante che
gli austriaci davano agli italiani, non soltanto l'esercito austriaco durante la guerra mondiale ma
un soprannome che risale addirittura al 700, che indicava già nel 700 e nell'800 gli emigranti italiani
in Austria, venditori ambulanti e così via. Questo soprannome era Katzelmacher, dove Katzelmacher
alla lettera vorrebbe dire fabbricante di gatti. I linguisti si sono interrogati naturalmente da dove
diavolo viene fuori questo soprannome e qualcuno dice ma sì sono quelli, gli italiani sono quelli che
fanno tanti figli come i gatti, noi diremmo come i conigli, no? Altri dicono no ci deve essere qualcosa
in comune con il fatto che gli italiani i gatti li mangiano, almeno gli emigrati italiani erano
sospettati di. La verità vera è che probabilmente il soprannome Katzelmacher deriva da una parola,
che qui non ripeterò, che gli austriaci sentivano continuamente in bocca agli italiani. Tant'è vero
che io ho trovato proprio nelle lettere di un ufficiale austriaco durante la guerra, alla vigilia
dell'offensiva del Piave, anche un'altra versione, questo dice adesso gliela faremo vedere ai
cazzolini, scritto sempre con la k e il tz naturalmente, ecco. Allora i Katzelmacher sono lì
dall'altra parte del Piave e noi austriaci stavolta gliela facciamo vedere. Come la chiamiamo
questa operazione? L'attacco di Caporetto fatto insieme da tedeschi e austriaci era stato battezzato
l'operazione fratellanza d'armi. Questa, sono gli austriaci da soli, la chiamano operazione
radetzchi, con l'idea che insomma gli italiani radetzchi se lo ricordano e ci torniamo a quei
bei tempi. Un po' ci credono, un po' devono far finta di crederci. L'imperatore Carlo I, nel frattempo
è morto nel XVI già il vecchio Francesco Giuseppe, adesso c'è Carlo d'Asburgo, l'ultimo
l'ultimo imperatore d'Austria, uno dei pochissimi santi che si ha occasione di incontrare raccontando
queste storie perché l'imperatore Carlo I, che era molto cattolico, è stato fatto santo da Papa
Giovanni Paolo II, il cui padre era sergente nel suo esercito. L'imperatore Carlo I dunque fa coniare
in anticipo la medaglia ricordo per l'ingresso a Venezia. È un po' presto ma insomma è meglio
portarsi avanti, sfonderemo sul piave e andremo a Venezia. Tanto per cambiare gli italiani sanno
benissimo che l'offensiva sta arrivando. Come sempre nella prima guerra mondiale è completamente
impossibile tenere segreti i preparativi, quindi attraverso le intercettazioni telefoniche, le spie,
i disertori, i comandi italiani sanno benissimo che l'ammazzata sta per arrivare. E mentre prima di
Caporetto erano stati molto tranquilli e sicuri di sé, adesso vogliono far vedere che hanno imparato
la lezione. Cosa è successo a Caporetto? Una marea di sbandati, centinaia di migliaia di sbandati.
Abbiamo dovuto allestire all'ultimo momento enormi campi per ospitare tutti questi sbandati.
Adesso alla vigilia dell'offensiva del piave, tanto per essere sicuri, i campi per accogliere i nostri
sbandati nelle retrovie li preparano già prima. Così se crolla tutto almeno siamo già pronti a
recuperare gli sbandati. Dopo Caporetto Cadorna aveva dovuto evacuare in fretta e furia da un giorno
all'altro il comando supremo di Vicenza. Adesso il comando supremo è a Padova, però se quelli
sfondano sul piave, fatto sta che un gruppetto di ufficiali dello Stato Maggiore viene mandato a
salso maggiore, che sembra abbastanza indietro, a cercare gli edifici per l'evacuazione del comando
supremo. Se dobbiamo abbandonare Padova almeno sappiamo già dove andare. Ma in realtà a parte questo,
questi sono gli aspetti umoristici, ma la preparazione italiana stavolta c'è invece.
Stavolta ecco è passato del tempo, sono passati otto besi da Caporetto. Gli eserciti in guerra
imparano in fretta. A Caporetto gli italiani si sono trovati di fronte a un nemico, i tedeschi,
che combatteva con tattiche tecniche che gli italiani avevano appena cominciato ad annusare ma
non le conoscevano ancora veramente ed è per quello che ci siamo sbriciolati. Ma otto mesi in guerra sono
un tempo enorme. Il nostro esercito ha imparato, i generali hanno studiato e si sono messe in pratica
le cose che sapevano fare i tedeschi e noi invece no. L'esempio più importante è l'uso
dell'artiglieria. Adesso entro un po' in un aspetto tecnico, ma non ha senso parlare di queste
battaglie senza sapere quali erano le condizioni tecniche in cui quegli uomini si trovavano a
combattere e a morire. Cos'è l'artiglieria? L'artiglieria significa questo. Nella prima guerra
mondiale quando si attacca si è svantaggiati, il nemico ha le mitragliatrici, le trincee, il filo
spinato e tu vai a farti ammazzare. Fin dai primi mesi della prima guerra mondiale si capisce questo.
Se tu vai all'attacco come ai vecchi tempi con la baionetta in canna e le bandiere al vento,
quelli ti massacrano, non ci arrivi neanche alle loro trincee. Allora la reazione dei generali è stata
di dire allora vuol dire che prima di attaccare li bombardiamo. Tanto abbiamo dei cannoni meravigliosi,
i cannoni negli ultimi anni hanno avuto dei progressi straordinari, gli scienziati che si
dedicano con zelo umanitario a questa cosa in tutti i paesi hanno inventato meravigliosi esplosivi
nuovi, non è solo Nobel che ha inventato la dinamite, tutti i laboratori sono lì che lavorano e producono
nuovi esplosivi, sempre più potenti. Abbiamo tutti, hanno un'artiglieria di una potenza che non
si era mai vista. Allora va bene, se vogliamo attaccare vuol dire che prima li bombardiamo,
così con l'artiglieria li radiamo al suolo, le loro trincee, il loro filo spinato, le loro
mitragliatrici. Bombardiamo anche per un giorno intero. All'inizio della prima guerra mondiale
sembra una cosa da pazzi, invece lo fanno. Per 24 ore si bombarda con tutto quello che costano
i proiettili, che hanno un costo infernale. Non importa, per 24 ore si bombarda e poi si va
all'attacco, vedrete, l'artiglieria avrà spianato tutto. Si va all'attacco e gli altri vengono fuori
dalle trincee e dalle rovine, tirano fuori le mitragliatrici e ti spianano di nuovo come prima.
Com'è successo? Succede che la gente in trincea è molto ben difesa contro il bombardamento e quando
il bombardamento si accentua la gente fa le trincee più profonde e comincia a fare i ripari
di cemento e i bunker e a lasciare in trincea solo qualcuno, le vedette, gli altri ben al riparo
dietro. Risultato? Bombardare per un giorno non serve a niente. Come funziona la mente umana? Funziona
così, che i generali dicono allora bombardiamo per due giorni e infatti si comincia a bombardare per due
giorni prima di attaccare. Va tutto allo stesso modo. Allora bombardiamo per tre giorni. Nel 1916
siamo arrivati al punto che prima di attaccare sulla Somme, primo luglio 1916, gli inglesi bombardano
per una settimana. Allora ovviamente non è che non fa niente bombardare per una settimana, uno non
vorrebbe essere nei panni dei fanti tedeschi che se ne stanno nascosti nei loro bunker per una settimana
con il mondo che gli esplode fuori. Fatto sta che neanche dopo una settimana non basta. Quando gli inglesi
vanno all'attacco ci sono ancora abbastanza tedeschi pronti per falciarli. A questo punto
sono sicuro che ci saranno stati dei generali che avranno detto beh allora otto giorni. Ma ci sono anche
dei generali tedeschi che dicono no pensiamoci un po' meglio a questa cosa. Bisogna cambiare sistema
totalmente. Tu cominci il bombardamento, gli altri sanno benissimo che tu bombarderai per giorni e
giorni e giorni e poi andrai all'attacco. Quindi si preparano, si sistemano e stanno lì ad aspettare.
Noi, dicono i tedeschi, potremmo provare a fare così. Bombardiamo solo per un'ora. Quando gli altri
hanno appena cominciato a mettersi al riparo il bombardamento finisce e i nostri vanno all'attacco
e li prendiamo di sorpresa. Questa cosa la provano, dice proviamola prima contro quelli un po' più
deboli. La provano contro i russi nell'estate autunno del 17, funziona a meraviglia. Dicono
proviamola contro degli altri anche loro deboli. La provano a Caporetto. Funziona a meraviglia. A
Caporetto interi battaglioni italiani vengono catturati nelle loro caverne perché erano lì
aspettandosi che il bombardamento durasse tutto il giorno e invece dopo un'ora il bombardamento
finisce e a quel punto mentre gli ufficiali dentro si stanno guardando e si stanno dicendo che facciamo
sarà una finta oppure usciamo e ci sono già i primi tedeschi all'ingresso della caverna che dicono
italiani arrendetevi. Ecco. E gli italiani che a Caporetto avevano una poderosa artiglieria non
l'hanno quasi usata. Perché? Perché non sapevano bene come usarla e non erano abituati a difendersi,
attaccavamo sempre noi. Quando attacchi tu gli ordini per l'artiglieria sono facili. La vedete
quella trincea laggiù, anzi sulla cartina, quel punto sulla cartina a otto chilometri. Voi bombardate
quel punto. Bombardatelo, 50 colpi al giorno, non dovete fare nient'altro. È diverso quando sono gli
altri che ti attaccano. Dove devi sparare? Chi è che ti dice dove devi sparare? La nostra artiglieria
era completamente impreparata. Ma fra Caporetto e il Piave fra l'ottobre 17 e il giugno 18 anche i
nostri ufficiali di artiglieria hanno studiato. Come fanno i tedeschi quando vengono attaccati? Ed è
passato un nuovo concetto che è la contropreparazione. Che vuol dire questo? Quando gli altri che ti vogliono
attaccare cominciano a sparare. Ecco nel caso di Caporetto gli ordini per i nostri cannoni erano
state bravi, tranquilli, zitti. Quando avete l'impressione che gli altri attaccano magari
cominciate a sparare però poco perché i proiettili costano. Adesso il discorso è completamente diverso.
I proiettili costano pazienza per una volta spendiamo. Il Piave bisogna tenerlo, c'è poco da fare, si gioca
il paese, si gioca la monarchia. Costi quel che costi che per una volta non vuol dire non importa quanti
morti ci saranno ma vuol dire non importa quanti soldi spendiamo. Quindi l'artiglieria ha questi
ordini, la contropreparazione che è la forma più moderna appena imparata che significa appena quelli
con mille cannoni cominciano a spararci noi rispondiamo con duemila cannoni e loro ci sparano
un giorno intero e anche noi gli spariamo un giorno intero. Spariamo ai loro cannoni, spariamo ai loro
comandi, ai loro magazzini, alle strade. Le truppe che vengono all'attacco dovranno passare da qualche
parte no? E noi spariamo lì continuamente senza risparmiare. È la prima volta che l'artiglieria
italiana si comporta sul Piave in modo moderno. La contropreparazione vuol dire che le truppe
austriache che si preparano all'attacco vengono schiacciate nelle loro trincee di partenza da una
marea di fuoco. Le truppe, i comandi, i centralini saltano i telefoni, comincia già male insomma.
Detto questo gli austriaci attaccano e sono talmente disperati che nonostante tutto passano
il Piave e costituiscono una testa di ponte al di qua del Piave. L'attacco scatta il 15 giugno e gli
austriaci passano sotto il bombardamento italiano che produce perdite spaventose però gli austriaci
vanno avanti, passano il Piave, gettano passerelle, portano al di là molte truppe. Intanto piove,
piove, piove, piove il 15 giugno, piove talmente tanto che il Piave si gonfia e dalla parte italiana
ovviamente stanno a vedere pregando che il fiume salga. Il fiume sale e finalmente porta via le
passerelle degli austriaci. Quelli che sono passati di qua rimangono bloccati. Nei giorni seguenti gli
austriaci continuamente ributtano passerelle sotto il bombardamento e traghettano gente dalla
nostra parte ma non riescono ad allargarsi e fin dal primo giorno le perdite sono spaventose. Già la
prima sera un ufficiale austriaco annota nel suo diario l'offensiva è completamente fallita, la nostra
artiglieria è miserabile spara sulle nostre stesse truppe, centinaia di uomini sono annegati,
continuano per cinque giorni e questa è la battaglia del Piave e dall'altra ci sono i nostri i quali non
lo sanno come andrà a finire e l'idea di una nuova caporetto che sta arrivando ce l'hanno in testa
tutti però i nostri tengono con fatica con perdite enormi anche i nostri però non crolla il fronte e gli
austriaci nella testa di ponte sono sotto il bombardamento e alla fine crollano loro dopo
cinque giorni il 20 il comando austriaco decide l'offensiva è fallita basta troppe perdite troppi
morti abbandoniamo la testa di ponte le truppe in realtà hanno già cominciato a abbandonarla loro
scappando al di là del Piave in tutti i modi anche a nuoto che col Piave in piena non è la migliore
delle idee l'ultimo giorno un ufficiale austriaco racconta all'alba dopo che abbiamo respinto un
violento attacco degli italiani perché gli italiani attaccano continuamente la testa di
ponte per ributtarli al di là del Piave arriva la notizia che a nord la linea è rotta e che le
truppe fuggono e la catastrofe i resti della fanteria sgombrano le trincee e corrono verso il
fiume un fuoco violentissimo li insegue e l'acqua gialla del Piave ribolle sotto le
esplosioni ininterrotte delle granate le acque del Piave portano a valle un numero enorme di
cadaveri battaglia del Piave è la vera grande vittoria italiana di questa guerra è la volta che
l'esercito italiano da solo da solo ci sono ancora inglesi e francesi ma il grosso siamo noi
davanti al nemico tradizionale gli austriaci che è un nemico alla nostra altezza per una volta
l'esercito italiano si è dimostrato superiore è superiore come tecnologie come tattiche e le
truppe combattono naturalmente la battaglia del Piave scatena anche un'ondata di propaganda e di
retorica è inevitabile in tutti i paesi belligeranti la propaganda domina incontrastata e la retorica è
spaventosa dappertutto battaglia del Piave ha lasciato alcune tracce nella memoria collettiva
italiana ricordate le scritte per esempio le foto che tutti abbiamo visto una volta nella vita il
pezzo di muro di una casa di roccata con sopra scritto tutti eroi o il Piave o tutti accoppati e
per tanto tempo si cercava di far credere che un soldato spontaneamente aveva scritto quella cosa poi
pian piano viene fuori che era il comando supremo che faceva fare queste scritte sui sui muri dentro
un'osteria compare un'altra scritta che diventerà molto famosa meglio vivere un giorno da leone che
cent'anni da pecora lì anni dopo verrà fuori un soldato che dirà sì sì l'ho scritta io quella cosa
mi dettava l'ufficiale e io scrivevo però anche queste cose servono i giornali ne parlano le
fotografie circolano tutti eroi e naturalmente un impiegato delle poste napoletano che ha già un
certo nome come paroliere autore di canzoni scrive in quei giorni una canzone che anche stamattina gli
alpini suonavano qui fuori e che credo tutti noi abbiamo sentito in vita nostra la canzone del Piave
il Piave mormorò impiegato delle poste si chiamava Giovanni Gaeta ma firma questa canzone con uno
pseudonimo come faceva spesso con le sue canzoni e a Mario
canzone a grandissimo successo il re Vittorio vuole conoscere l'autore lo fanno andare al Quirinale il re
Vittorio riceve Giovanni Gaeta che ha firmato e a Mario e gli dice ma scusi però questo questo
pseudonimo da dove viene fuori dice Gaeta è perché io sono un grande ammiratore di Alberto Mario che era
un collaboratore di Mazzini era un grande Mazziniano e il re dice ah capito perché lei si dice Gaeta io
sono repubblicano dopodiché se è vera la cosa che circola ma pare sia vera o comunque è stata
venduta così segno dei vecchi tempi il re dice vabbè i repubblicani sono sempre stati dei fedeli
servitori del paese la nomino commendatore della corona d'Italia dopodiché naturalmente io mi fermerei
ancora un attimo perché questa canzone che tutti conosciamo è uno straordinario esempio di propaganda
e di mistificazione propagandistica perché qual è la situazione noi siamo sul piave e stiamo
combattendo per difendere il paese da un'invasione nemica sul piave l'esercito resiste per impedire che
il nemico che già occupa un pezzo d'Italia vada anche oltre non passa lo straniero ma come tutti
ricordate la canzone evoca il 24 maggio il piave mormorava calmo e placido al passaggio dei primi
fanti il 24 maggio l'esercito marciava per raggiungere la frontiera per far contro il nemico
una barriera dove sta la mistificazione intanto che il 24 maggio il piave non c'entrava niente era
nelle retrovie lontanissimo dal fronte ma soprattutto nel fatto che il 24 maggio del 15 l'esercito non
marciava verso la frontiera per far contro il nemico una barriera andavamo noi a invadere loro
siamo noi che il 24 maggio abbiamo sfondato la frontiera e invaso la slovenia austriaca il
trentino austriaco stavamo invadendo il paese nemico adesso dopo caporetto non se ne ricorda più
nessuno dopo caporetto la parola d'ordine si fa questa guerra per difendere l'italia dall'invasione
e anche il piave viene arruolato in questa battaglia bene entro il 20 giugno 1918 l'offensiva
austriaca la battaglia del solstizio come viene chiamata è fallita abbiamo vinto teniamo la linea
del piave intanto nel mondo cosa sta succedendo bene il mondo ormai vuol dire in francia perché la
russia è fuori dalla guerra dopo la rivoluzione lenin ha mantenuto la parola che aveva dato pace
subito e ha firmato la pace i tedeschi ormai combattono solo sul fronte occidentale dove hanno
di fronte i soliti vecchi nemici i francesi e gli inglesi però anche un nemico nuovo che non è magari
tanto esperto ma arriva con tanti uomini e tanta roba gli americani tutti hanno fatto gli stessi calcoli
gli americani entro pochi mesi avranno un milione di uomini in francia per fine anno ne avranno tre
milioni è completamente impossibile continuare perciò il comando supremo tedesco decide che
bisogna finire la guerra subito ci giochiamo il tutto per tutto e ludendorpe il capo di stato
maggiore tedesco pianifica una serie di offensive sul fronte francese che dovranno arrivare una dopo
l'altra con le stesse tattiche che erano servite a sbriciolare gli italiani a caporetto tattiche nuove
di movimento della fanteria di uso delle armi leggere di uso dell'artiglieria queste cinque
offensive partono una dopo l'altra a partire da marzo e le prime hanno un successo schiacciante
eco e consolante i tedeschi con gli stessi sistemi con cui avevano fracassato noi a caporetto nel marzo
del 18 fracassano gli inglesi annientano un'intera armata inglese vanno avanti di 60 chilometri poi però gli
altri sono troppi e questa offensiva si ferma parte la seconda va avanti e si ferma parte la terza
marzo aprile maggio giugno parte la quarta luglio parte la quinta ognuna di queste offensive sono
centinaia di migliaia di morti feriti dispersi ogni volta i tedeschi vanno un po più avanti sono
quasi a parigi ma quasi e intanto stanno finendo tutto però stanno finendo le riserve gli uomini i
soldi le munizioni tutto e anche la voglia la quinta offensiva che parte il 15 luglio è un disastro
viene fermata subito tanto che entro tre giorni il comando tedesco decide di sospenderla e a questo
punto gli alleati partono all'attacco loro ormai c'è il milione di americani ci sono le armi nuove i
carri armati che hanno appena inventato e che funzionano l'otto agosto per la prima volta da
anni gli alleati passano all'attacco in francia e i tedeschi cedono i tedeschi cominciano a
arretrare a partire da quel momento non si fermano più a metà settembre i tedeschi sono stati respinti
fino alla frontiera sapete che la guerra lì si è combattuta tutta in francia perché in belgio e
francia perché i tedeschi nel 14 erano entrati in belgio e in francia avevano conquistato un grosso
pezzo di terreno e l'hanno sempre tenuto nel settembre del 18 i tedeschi sono stati ributtati
alle loro frontiere e non sembra che riescano a fermarsi è chiaro a tutti che la guerra sta finendo
e che i tedeschi e gli austriaci hanno perso il 13 settembre l'imperatore carlo d'asburgo comunica
agli alleati che vuole aprire dei negoziati per chiedere la pace il 5 ottobre anche i tedeschi
contatteranno il presidente americano wilson per dire che loro sarebbero disposti a discutere della
pace e dunque attraverso tutti questi mesi noi il 20 giugno abbiamo assistito al fallimento
dell'offensiva austriaca mentre in francia si combatteva la quarta delle grandi offensive tedesche
a luglio si scatena la quinta offensiva tedesca in francia e fallisce subito e noi stiamo fermi
sul piave ad agosto gli alleati attaccano in francia e respingono i tedeschi e noi stiamo fermi
sul piave a settembre l'imperatore carlo comunica che lui vuole trattare la pace e noi stiamo fermi
sul piave perché nessuno al comando supremo italiano pensa che abbiamo le forze per provare
ad attaccare noi noi stiamo fermi a roma i politici cominciano a preoccuparsi perché vista da roma la
situazione è signori qui questa guerra sta per finire e se questa guerra finisce e gli altri in francia
ributtano i tedeschi in germania invadono la germania e noi siamo ancora sul piave col nemico
in casa e la guerra finisce e noi abbiamo il nemico in casa che figura ci facciamo con che faccia andiamo
poi dagli alleati a dire noi vogliamo bolzano l'istria la dalmazia quelli ci diranno ma intanto se vi
ridiamo il veneto perciò la politica a roma che ha perfettamente ragione su questo e vede chiarissimamente
come andranno le cose comincia a essere preoccupata perché l'esercito non si muove a luglio da roma
cominciano le prime telefonate a diaz e a badoglio suo vice per dire ragazzi forse dovreste muovervi
non siamo ancora pronti ad agosto il presidente del consiglio vittorio emmanuele orlando va di
persona a padova al comando supremo per dire a diaz e a badoglio dovete assolutamente attaccare
ci serve una vittoria testualmente anche una piccola vittoria una cosa da niente ma una vittoria
dobbiamo poterla mettere sul piatto diaz risponde che lui non accetta pressioni politiche e che piuttosto
si dimette orlando presidente del consiglio nelle sue memorie dirà a quel punto ci ho pensato ma non
sapevo chi mettere al suo posto quindi non se ne fa niente però insiste orlando dovete attaccare alla
fine il capo di stato maggiore badoglio scusate il vice del capo badoglio gli dice sentite noi sappiamo
che non siamo pronti ad attaccare se il governo ci vuole obbligare ad attaccare ci deve dare l'ordine
scritto è una roba che non si è mai vista il governo non va a dare ordini ai militari in questi
termini orlando dice no l'ordine scritto non ve lo do la responsabilità è vostra badoglio risponde
ma allora perché viene fin quassù a infelicitarci pare che badoglio da buon contadino piemontese con
l'italiano abbia sempre avuto qualche momento di a questo punto diaz ha la grande idea dobbiamo fare
qualcosa ma da soli non ci riusciamo andiamo a vedere se gli alleati sono disposti a trasferire
tutto il loro esercito in italia e attaccare insieme a noi diaz va a parigi il 6 settembre e porta la
proposta di trasferire in italia il grosso dell'esercito francese dicendo e voi con i tedeschi è
difficile quelli sono dei duri se venite da noi gli austriaci crollano i francesi gli dicono abbi pazienza
diaz ma a questo punto diaz ha un'altra idea brillante ci sono gli americani va dal generale
comandante l'esercito americano in francia il generale pershing il quale generale pershing nelle
sue memorie lo racconta dice è arrivato diaz e mi dice avremmo bisogno in italia di 20 divisioni
americani un milione di uomini pershing dice ero abituato a sentirmi chiedere di tutto perché
capite come sono arrivati gli americani e lo zio d'america sono straricchi hanno tutto tutti vanno
da loro e quindi pershing dice non ho battuto ciglio perché ero abituato a sentirmi chiedere le
cose più folli diaz vedendo che non battevo ciglio ha subito aumentato dice 25 divisioni
pershing dice ahimè mi son stupito che un uomo in quella posizione potesse fare sul serio dei
discorsi del genere e gli chiede diaz ma perché non attaccate voi e diaz dice stiamo studiando la
cosa però se attacchiamo adesso rischiamo di restare senza riserve in primavera capite il
settembre del 18 i tedeschi sono quasi stati respinti fino alle loro frontiere e diaz tira
fuori che attaccheremo la primavera prossima ecco da roma insistono no dovete attaccare prima a questo
punto diaz studia un piano lo fa studiare i suoi uffici per un piccolo attacco al di là del piave il
piano è pronto alla fine di settembre il 29 settembre si tiene una riunione dei generali per decidere voi
credete che dovessero decidere la data dell'offensiva invece decidono la data di una nuova riunione
futura in cui decideranno la data dell'offensiva la riunione la fissano fra due settimane per il 12
ottobre a quel punto sarà un mese che l'imperatore carlo ha già detto che lui vuole la pace e perfino i
tedeschi l'hanno già detto a roma la politica tumultua si va a finire come nel 1866 una guerra
ridicola in cui gli alleati i nostri alleati vincono e noi ci facciamo la solita figura è una
vergogna non si può la camera tumultua bisogna che l'esercito attacchi orlando presidente del
consiglio manda un telegramma al comando supremo tra l'inazione e la sconfitta preferisco la sconfitta
muovetevi nel frattempo il mondo sta crollando il 29 settembre la bulgaria alleata degli imperi
centrali ha firmato la pace è chiaro che è questione di poche settimane non solo il mondo
sta crollando ecco mi fermo un momento su questo l'austria sta crollando l'impero austriaco si sta
disgregando da solo perché mentre l'imperatore carlo ha contattato wilson presidente americano ed è
disposto a fare la pace sulla base dei 14 punti di wilson che dicevano autodeterminazione per i popoli
e l'imperatore carlo va avanti addirittura precede wilson il 16 ottobre l'imperatore carlo pubblica un
proclama in cui dichiara che le regioni polacche dell'impero sono libere di andarsene se vogliono
unirsi con altri territori polacchi e formare una nuova polonia lo possono fare e la parte ungherese
può essere indipendente se vuole e la parte austriaca diventerà uno stato federale di quattro
nazionalità tedesca cieca jugoslava e ucraina questo proclama ufficialmente l'imperatore carlo
il 16 ottobre gli americani rispondono ormai è troppo tardi questi popoli faranno quello che
vogliono loro e non quello che gli offri tu la pace si farà soltanto sulla base del fatto che ogni
nazionalità dell'impero austriaco decide in piena libertà tutto quello che vuole fare in effetti
il 14 ottobre si è già formato un governo nazionale ciecoslovacco all'interno dell'impero
austriaco che ha dichiarato guerra all'austria la croazia regione dell'impero austriaco sta
negoziando con la serbia paese nemico per creare la jugoslavia il 28 ottobre è proclamata la
ciecoslovacchia indipendente il 29 ottobre è proclamata la jugoslavia il 31 ottobre l'ungheria
si proclama indipendente questo è quello che succede nel corso del mese di ottobre da noi il
12 ottobre si è fatta la riunione per decidere quando cominciare l'attacco hanno deciso lo cominciamo
il 18 ottobre senza fretta per l'appunto si scoprirà in seguito che i parlamentari austriaci
designati per venire a chiederci l'armistizio erano pronti già dal 13 ottobre le loro credenziali
per negoziare erano datate 13 ottobre però il comando austriaco ha detto beh però finché gli
italiani non si muovono e finché il nostro esercito regge stiamo a vedere e aspettiamo
diaz ha ordinato l'attacco per il 18 ottobre cosa succede il 18 ottobre sul piave che piove diluvia il
piave in piena intransitabile rimandano di una settimana al 24 ottobre c'è di buono che l'anniversario
di caporetto intanto l'esercito austriaco sta cominciando a disgregarsi da solo il 20 ottobre i primi
reggimenti ungheresi in val sugana decidono di ammutinarsi e si mettono in marcia per tornarsene
in ungheria finalmente il 24 ottobre attacchiamo attacchiamo prima sul grappa per attirare lì
l'attenzione degli austriaci e poi dopo due giorni sul piave per passarlo e sfondare comincia la battaglia
di vittorio veneto che nei primi giorni è una vera battaglia questo va detto quei primi due giorni in cui
i nostri attaccano sul grappa sono giorni pesanti perché l'esercito austriaco nonostante tutto
l'esercito di un impero che sta finendo di esistere questo esercito contro gli italiani ha ancora voglia
di combattere per cui nei primi giorni gli austriaci tengono la sera del 26 si gettano le prime passerelle
sul piave la notte la piena spazza via tutto la notte del 27 si rifanno i ponti il 28 il piave li spazza via di nuovo
però intanto i nostri stanno passando c'è una prima testa di ponte al di là del piave entro il 29 abbiamo
grosse forze al di là del piave e a questo punto la battaglia di vittorio veneto in realtà è finita
perché l'esercito austriaco decide che basta le truppe austriache sono fatte in gran parte di uomini
nella cui patria nuovi governi stanno proclamando l'indipendenza la pace e così via nessuno ha più
voglia di combattere al di là del fatto che crepano di fame i prigionieri austriaci catturati a vittorio
veneto peseranno in media 45 chili l'uno dopodiché dopo di che gli austriaci l'esercito comincia a
ritirarsi e il 29 ottobre 10 del mattino il giorno in cui è proclamata a zagabria l'indipendenza
della jugoslavia i parlamentari austriaci arrivano a chiedere l'armistizio mentre il comando austriaco
ordina alle truppe a quei pochi che ancora obbediscono la ritirata fino alla frontiera e
quella cosa che dirà diaz nel proclama della vittoria no risalgono in disordine le valli che
avevano disceso con orgogliosa sicurezza bene apparentemente va tutto meravigliosamente l'impero
austriaco il nostro vecchio nemico secolare sta scomparendo al suo posto nascono nuovi paesi
dovremmo essere contentissimi in realtà attenzione la politica italiana fin dall'inizio sa che questa
guerra si fa per imporre la nostra egemonia nell'adriatico nei balcani e allora non è detto
che siamo così contenti certo se nasce la polonia non ci importa niente la cecoslovacchia va anche
bene ma la jugoslavia no la jugoslavia ai nostri politici non piace per niente l'idea che invece di
tanti piccoli stati nasca un grosso stato alla nostra frontiera e si sa già benissimo che gli
jugoslavi ai negoziati per la pace diranno trieste ma trieste è slava gorizia ma gorizia è slava l'istria
fiume la dalmazia neanche per idea quindi per i nostri in realtà la jugoslavia è un incubo
vi racconto uno specifico episodio molti di voi l'avranno sentito forse nominare perché da
bambini si studiava addirittura a scuola l'affondamento della viribus unitis la viribus
unitis è una corazzata austriaca una delle poche che gli rimangono ancorata nel porto di pola la notte
del tre la sera del 31 ottobre con un'azione di gruppi d'assalto con cui siamo in cui siamo così
bravi la nostra marina è sempre stata brava in queste cose due fegatacci entrano nel porto di
pola con una nuova arma speciale una mina semovente che viene agganciata di nascosto sotto la tolda
della corazzata viribus unitis poi i due sommozzatori paolucci e rossetti che becheranno la medaglia d'oro
tutti e due per questo ovviamente escono fuori gli austriaci li vedono li catturano e dopodiché poche
ore dopo la viribus unitis salta e affonda con gran parte del suo equipaggio con il suo comandante
31 ottobre
peccato che il 29 ottobre era stata proclamata l'indipendenza della jugoslavia
e il 30 ottobre l'imperatore carlo aveva regalato la sua flotta alla jugoslavia
quindi il 31 ottobre poche ore prima che paolucci e rossetti arrivassero nel porto di pola a minare la
corazzata a bordo della corazzata viribus unitis il nome è un vecchio slogan dell'impero austriaco
no vuol dire a forze unite e piaceva anche gli jugoslavi evidentemente a bordo della viribus
unitis l'ammiraglio horti comandante in capo della marina austriaca aveva solennemente consegnato la
corazzata ai rappresentanti jugoslavi la corazzata aveva innalzato bandiera jugoslava e il comandante
della corazzata capitano di vascello ianko wukovic von pod kapelski aveva preso il comando della flotta
jugoslava poche ore dopo noi affondiamo la principale corazzata della flotta jugoslava con il suo equipaggio
croato a bordo e con a bordo il comandante della marina jugoslava che affoga durante l'affondamento
della corazzata e io non so se paolucci e rossetti lo sapessero ma i loro comandi lo sapevano benissimo
che cosa stava succedendo e nessuno ha detto vabbè visto che adesso la corazzata jugoslava lasciamo
perdere anzi dunque il 29 ottobre gli austriaci chiedono l'armistizio sarebbero pronti a firmare
anche subito tanto ormai è finita l'austria non esiste più e l'esercito si sta ritirando in
disordine e gli italiani inseguono a questo punto siamo noi che tiriamo in lungo perché dovremmo
firmare un armistizio quando il nemico sta scappando noi lo inseguiamo catturiamo prigionieri e liberiamo
la patria occupata e andiamo avanti e saremmo così stupidi da fermarci no no comando austriaco
cioè il negoziatore austriaco a villa giusti a padova il generale weber von webenau appena cominciano i
colloqui dichiara che loro in pratica hanno già deposto le armi non intendono più combattere e
chiedono di cessare immediatamente i combattimenti e fermare l'avanzata italiana i negoziatori italiani
rispondono non se ne parla neanche adesso discutiamo le clausole dell'armistizio e finché
non abbiamo messo nero su bianco le clausole dell'armistizio il nostro esercito continua a
attaccare e a inseguire si tira avanti il più che si può finalmente quando non ci sono più pretesti
gli austriaci hanno ceduto tutto quello che chiedevamo alle 18 e 40 del 3 novembre viene firmato
l'armistizio riusciamo ancora a infilarci un trucco è firmato alle 18 40 del 3 novembre ma
entrerà in vigore alle 15 del giorno dopo migliaia di soldati austriaci che non hanno capito questa
cosa quella sera quella notte quel mattino dopo vedono arrivare gli italiani li salutano allegramente
e vengono immediatamente catturati e fatti prigionieri alla fine di tutto questo i nostri
sono quasi a innsbruck siamo sbarcati a trieste per il rotto della cuffia siamo riusciti a prenderci
quel che volevamo abbiamo in mano 300.000 prigionieri quasi tutti uomini che credevano che la guerra fosse
finita e stavano tornando a casa invece resteranno ancora parecchi mesi in prigionia italiana adibiti ai
lavori forzati devo dire ci sono rarissime testimonianze di questi prigionieri austriaci che
sono rimasti in prigionia appunto fino al marzo aprile del 19 in italia la prigionia degli italiani
in austria era stata spaventosa per la fame tremenda nei lager ma anche le testimonianze dei prigionieri
austriaci trattenuti in italia fino al 19 le poche che ho letto parlano solo di quello fame fame
disperata maltrattamenti la stessa identica cosa che i nostri hanno subito nei lager dopodiché abbiamo
vinto abbiamo vinto la battaglia di vittorio veneto e abbiamo vinto la guerra e come dire non è un bel
momento a guardarlo da adesso perché i nostri perdono la testa diaz diaz scrive alla moglie nei
giorni dei negoziati noi negoziamo e imponiamo le nostre condizioni se per caso gli austriaci non
accettassero le nostre condizioni e qui cito continueremo e sarà un disastro per l'esercito
nemico dopo del quale muoveremo contro la germania ove resista e così saremo noi a dare la pace alla
francia invece di riceverla questo scrive il comandante dell'esercito italiano in quei giorni
in cui i tedeschi stanno crollando anche sul fronte occidentale e i francesi stanno per entrare in germania
ma noi diciamo noi abbiamo vinto la guerra per tutti i giornali italiani ovviamente si scatenano
mussolini più di tutti un titolo fra tutti del popolo d'italia emblematico dello spirito del tempo la causa
santa della civiltà trionfa dove noi siamo la causa santa della civiltà
leggere oggi è facile lo so che è facile la mentalità di allora era quella forse perfino
ingeneroso prendere le distanze adesso però bisogna farlo uno legge certi articoli dei giornalisti
italiani al seguito delle truppe di queste truppe che stanno via via respingendo gli austriaci e
rioccupando i territori occupati scrive guelfo civinini sul corriere della sera dove è stato
l'austriaco è rimasto il suo tanfo e il suo sudiciume e le strade per cui è fuggito sono seminate di
elmetti di armi di cenci luridi di mollettiere fangose scioltesi nella fuga dai suoi stinchi
pidocchiosi non sembra di battere le strade della ritirata di un esercito ma quelle per cui un'invasione
di zingari è stata scacciata dai suoi feti di accampamenti e insomma per finire aveva ragione
prezzolini il quale amava i paradossi e a un certo punto è scritto che per l'italia caporetto è stata
una vittoria e vittorio veneto una sconfitta caporetto ci ha fatto bene e vittorio veneto ci ha fatto male
caporetto ci ha innalzati dice prezzolini e vittorio veneto ci ha abbassati perché ci si fa grandi
resistendo a una sventura e spiando le proprie colpe e si diventa invece piccoli gonfiandosi con
le menzogne e facendo risorgere i cattivi istinti per il fatto di vincere questo diceva prezzolini non lo
dico io però del vero c'era il che non toglie niente al fatto che i nostri nonni hanno combattuto
quella mia nonno anche era lì terza armata l'invitta terza armata del duca d'aosta i nostri nonni e
bisnonni hanno combattuto quella guerra si sono fatti ammazzare in 600.000 hanno passato delle cose
che oggi sono inimmaginabili alla fine hanno vinto però quel paese vittorioso ha scoperto alla fine di
essere un paese con le ossa rotte indebitato fino al collo con una disoccupazione spaventosa un
malessere sociale dilagante e tutti che dicevano noi dovremmo avere molto da questa vittoria non ci
vogliono dare tutto quello che ci spetta noi dovremmo essere forti potenti comandare avere un impero non ce lo
vogliono dare gliela faremo vedere noi la prossima volta ecco non è uscita bene da quella guerra
l'italia se ci pensate i paesi che hanno vinto quella guerra l'inghilterra la francia sono usciti
anche loro disastrati con un'economia molto mal ridotta disoccupazione spaventosa scioperi ma lì non ci
sono stati sono movimenti sociali la democrazia ha tenuto la democrazia è andata al diavolo nel
dopoguerra nei paesi sconfitti tra rivoluzioni e contro rivoluzioni in germania in austria in
ungheria l'italia se uno guarda quello che c'è successo nel dopoguerra assomiglia più ai paesi
sconfitti che non ai paesi che la guerra l'avevano vinta davvero e anche questa è una cosa su cui come
dire vale la pena di riflettere grazie